a partir de ahora con la rectificación
próxima en las próximas semanas de la
entrada de Finlandia la otan los caminos
de Finlandia Suecia quedarán
completamente separados el presidente
turcos ha explicado delante de su
homólogo finlandés para que tenía muy
buenas palabras las malas palabras e
incluso malos deseos que hablaba que
tenía con el Primer Ministro sueco al
que he dicho que es buena persona pero
que no cumple según erdogan con Los
acuerdos que firmaron los tres países
Finlandia Suecia y Turquía en la Cumbre
del verano pasado de la otan en Madrid
sobre todo el don ancha quejado de que
Finlandia no ha deportado a Turquía a
120 supuestos terroristas según Turquía
que el país sanatorio quiere que sean
deportados a su país no lo han hecho
según explicado varias veces la justicia
y el gobierno sueco que estas
deportaciones no pueden pasar porque la
justicia sueca considera que si estas
personas a las que Turquía acusa de ser
terroristas fuesen deportadas hacia
Turquía no recibirían en este país un
juicio justo sin embargo
a partir de ahora Finlandia sí que
entrará en la otra en las próximas
semanas espera después de que el
documento que ha firmado hoy el
presidente Turco respecta y perdón se ha
mandado al parlamento Turco para la
ratificación de este de la entrada de
Finlandia a la alianza atlántica algo se
espera que pasen las próximas semanas
sobre todo porque el parlamento Turco
tendrá que ser disuelto A mediados del
mes que viene mediados de abril para
entrar en la convocatoria electoral que
Turquía tiene prevista para el 14 de
mayo tendremos por lo tanto un plazo de
un mes para que Turquía ratifique la
entrada de Finlandia dentro de la otan